In the unit, we've been discussing fixed parameter tractable problems
and there are a lot of new things about these.
First, the exponential part of the running time is restricted to the parameter k rather than
the parameter n, and at least in many cases k is much less than n.
Another new thing is that they provably allow for some very effective pre-processing rules
and the details of some of these are a little bit out of scope for this course,
but we can get a bit of a taste for them by working at vertex cover and noticing a few key insights.
Now, let's say we have a graph G and suppose it has n vertices along with parameter k,
now what I'd like to know is does she have a vertex cover of size at most k.
So in other words, we were discussing the decision variant of the vertex cover problem.
Another way of saying this is that at most a certain number of vertices are needed
to cover all the edges and this could be either k-1, k, 2k, k+n, or n.
Another fact that this question or the answer to this question will imply is that if any vertex
is an endpoint to a certain number of edges or more, then it must be in the cover,
and this could be either k-1, k, k+1, 2k, or k² edges.
So for both of these questions, please check whichever on is most appropriate.